I thought having a boyfriend that the
idea of other boys left her mind
completely I didn't want to be thinking
about what might have been but I was so
this movie sparked a worldwide debate
obviously on who Laura Jean should be
Dasher team John first team Peter so I'm
gonna ask you and Noah different
questions we're gonna present a lot of
the answers and she'll decide the
general or you team okay so um give me
your best pick-up line best pick-up line
hey how's your heart Wow I gotta pick my
heart of genuine question you know and I
asked I asked my friends that and I
asked my fiancee that I asked like you
know but it's a rule it's a real
question is what is your best pick-up
line
[Music]
Largey we've been together for so long
and I want to be together for the rest
of my life that's a good pickup I don't
know if he would say something like that
so is the bet the better pickup line hey
how was your heart or Laura Jean I love
you so much
hey how is your heart okay what's your
ideal first date spot ideal first date
spot is a date it's a date where we can
talk I love food I love wine I love like
you know that that to me is a very
sensory experience and so I think that
like like a chef's tasting nothing
that's like to to in a dating like a
chef's table we're like we go in the
back and do the thing like you know I
think that like something where the
decision in terms of food itself is like
very easily made but like hey let's
let's do like a like a prefix and have
some fun and like do wine pairings is
great because it extends the time like
sitting down and then like every dish
that's put down every new glass of wine
that's put down a they pair very well
together but it brings up new thoughts
and conversations and like every time
you take a bite of something new and
fresh it can like it's all sensory so it
didn't it incites like different thought
processes so I think anytime where you
can sit and you can talk for an extended
period of time and also like nourish
yourself you're happy and orphans are
flowing like that to me is a really good
first date what is your ideal first date
spot ooh
Peter Peter would love to go to some
place you know he likes it
to a large into like you know and I
should tell you restaurant you know do a
little do a little Goodfellas or
something maybe you know try to throw
back to one of his favorite movies first
date location are you going to an
Italian restaurant or are you going to a
restaurant where you can do food
pairings like with wine I know I mean
listen I'm forever gonna pick Italian
just because I know there's wine on that
restaurant listen let's be real and I
can't go a day without eating noodles I
don't the ones you were eating on
Instagram list and I look so good are
you calling or texting or after calling
calling I'm I hate texting and just in
general I'm kind of old school like my
favorite my favorite means of
communication is face to face and if not
that FaceTime if not that phone call
after the first day are you calling her
texting out there Peters you call her
why you like to hear the voice something
you can't really get across in text okay
so they're both calling you after the
day instead of texting you okay most
romantic movie to watch most romantic
movie to watch my favorite of all time
is actually Love Actually I love it
because it's very human oriented all of
these relationships and sources somehow
somehow connected also anything that
Emma Thompson or Alan Rickman ever does
or did rest in peace is gold to me like
they have the hands of Midas like I'm a
fan of whatever they ever touch ever
period ever the end ever so I I think
that because it's so many different
types of relationships and journeys and
whatnot are all explored within that
it's like you kid it's kind of like a
chef's tasting again in film what is the
most romantic movie it's all the boys I
love
I've left before to all the boys PS I
still love you is even more romantic if
you ask me and then the third one
somehow
beats the second one what is the more
romantic movie to watch to all the boys
I've loved before PS I love you or Love
Actually after the date wait well in
general I couldn't add a pic of romantic
movie to watch it you come on yes I
still love you you guys go on yes okay
you are
team Peter I am I am I switch but right
now in the moment listen last night it
was pretty difficult because I there was
the fan screen and and I stayed and
watched in the back and I was like
leaning cuz it I hadn't seen the movie
for a while and so I was leading to team
John but I'm good I'm gonna stick with
team Peter for now cuz like ogee but
also you know it's like you date a Peter
you marry a John oh you just said it
right here I love it
did you always go back and forth like in
your head is the character yeah
yeah and as a Lana like I would go home
at night angry at Largey and after
working I'd be like driving home and I'd
be like what are you doing they're so
great what's happening I was genuinely
confused when we shot the piano scene
with Jordan and I my heart broke into a
million pieces because every part of my
heart I was largely I was like stay so
yeah I'm like torn so I asked Noah and
Jordan separate questions to you know
sort of answer that debate team John
verse team Peter and I told Lana what
the answer was and the winner was team
Peter oh wait on both of them on yeah
what are yours oh um I thought you know
what I keep saying it but I really mean
it is my M team Laura Jean so I that's
how I approached it when I wrote the
story is like whatever I think she
really wants deep in her heart what can
you tell us about the third movie
not much what do you tell me though tell
you I'll tell you later I'll say that
it's um you know what I love about the
third story is I wasn't originally gonna
do a third book but then I think that
there's something really special about
starting out the further the first movie
starts out with her feeling really sad
about her sister going to college and
also judging Margo a little bit for
choosing a breakup with her boyfriend
and part of the reason why I wrote one
more story was because I
wanted to seal our gene come full circle
and have her own moment so I love that
and I know you're really close with your
sister too so I love ya really good
sister yeah that's amazing can you give
me your best know us internet
impersonation yeah listen I mean like
what does it mean to be like happy it's
like it's like happiness is kind of like
relevant and like I don't really know
how I feel right now but like but like
it's it's it's dope you know
Laxus poetic as soon as these are
talking to him nobody confess you
[Music]